comme hawaï depuis montréal ricardo
botero prend des nouvelles de sa maman
collonges dans le village de manille ça
laisse au coeur du pays
daisy raconte à son fils que les rayons
des supermarchés se vident de jour en
jour depuis le début de la pandémie
ricardo botero se faisait un sang
d'encre pour la santé de sa famille
l'insécurité rampante dans le pays a
ajouté à son angoisse
moi je me sens en détresse avec ces
situations là parce que évidemment je
peux rien faire d'ici juste le support
moral
le peuple fait pression sur le président
yves indiqué et son gouvernement depuis
neuf jours la démission hier du ministre
des finances n'a pas apaisé la
contestation et après la répression
brutale des manifestants qui a fait une
vingtaine de morts
l'appel au dialogue lancé aujourd'hui
par le gouvernement ne convainc par aéro
millan qui vit à cali l'épicentre des
manifestations et où la violence a fait
plusieurs morts
les hommes ont indiqué par les avait
tous les organisations qui ont participé
dans la grève générale d etat ni mais
finalement ne pas produire on fait
vraiment et ont cité comme
de cali à montréal la peur et
l'insécurité règnent et pour se sentir
moins impuissant face à la crise que
traverse son pays natal comment moi
ricardo botero a appelé à un
rassemblement pacifique auquel plus
d'une centaine de colombiens ont
participé mais en colombie c'est
toujours comme ça tu dis quelque chose
je n'étais pas supposé dire bien
évidemment tu disparais sont en train
d'enlever notre vie juste parce qu'on
est en train de manifester pour nos
droits qu'on est fâché puis on est
fatigué par la première la dernière fois
qu'ils font ça qu'elle témoigne de sa
solide à l'assemblée nationale du québec
on sent une motion a été adoptée suivi
d'une minute de silence à la mémoire des
victimes
ici à 6000 khayat radio canada montréal